pour commencer cette soirée de réveillon
vous prendrez bien un cocktail vocal
jean alcool demande essayer ou ses divas
voici monsieur et qu'elle vous il ya
toujours un fanion de nos cocktails ça
une jolie couleur mais c'est plein de
mails à manger je ne tiens pas avoir la
gueule de bois quoi l'héritan définition
du devoir contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser je vais la lire parce
que j'accueille mort à coeur c'est avoir
la bouche empâtée et sèche par suite de
l'excellent d'accord alors j'aurai
quelques conseils simples pour éviter
les désagréments des retours de fait le
premier éviter les mélanges le deuxième
ne les ai pas remplir notre maire invita
ne sent rien alors qu'un verre aux trois
quarts vide embaume la consommation de
vin doit se faire en mangeant et puis
n'hésitez pas à demander une carafe
d'eau et un verre à la maîtresse de
maison et en s'inclinant patron de
volonté je pense que nous sommes
nombreux
il n'y a quand même les bons vieux à
mettre de grands mères non ajoutez y les
classiques puis en une deux rives
à mon grand pas que je n'ai jamais testé
mais qui paraît-il le centre efficace
sinon un court en dur tarn vous pouvez
toujours pour ceux qui coquillaud et
digestion difficile prendre de me
fatiguer somika qu'un ca chambre à une
dose un petit peu le sorbitol un peu de
de citrate de bétaïne et puis bien
entendu il existe aussi un moyen radical
à la fin du repas mais celui-ci
c'est pareil je n'ai jamais expérimenté
c'est prendre un café bien salée santé
alors dire d'urnes et l'a même fait même
quand on est toujours difficile mais moi
j'ai une bonne formule en tant que
médecin du sport
je me lève le matin je prends un grand
verre d'eau pas glacé je mets un peu de
citron 1 aspirine paracétamol ce nom en
état ensuite une bonne douche un café
serré
j'enfile non survêtement et puis je vais
m'aérer autour du lac pour éliminer et
puis retiré un petit peu tout ces
toxines qui ont envahi les cellules et
c'est reparti pour une année et c'est
reparti pour une année alors voix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]